RADHIKA MALPANI: Welcome
to the second
Women Techmakers series.
This series highlights stories
of women in technology,
especially women focused
on social good.
Our goal is to inspire women
to get into technology.
And here at the Google
Developers network, we have
tools to help you
do exactly that.
We are very excited to have with
us today Julie Hanna, the
chairman of Kiva.
My name is Radhika.
I'm an engineer and director
here with Google.
And I have been here
for over 13 years,
working mostly in search.
I was responsible for Google's
image search and have lately
been working on travel.
My co-host today is Anita.
Anita?
ANITA YUEN: Yes.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Anita Yuen.
I have been at Google for
six and a half years.
I spent my first four years
leading our marketing
initiatives around Google's
consumer search products, as
well as our homepage products.
And I spent the last two years
now leading our marketing
initiatives around Google's
technology for good, which
includes things such as crisis
response, energy and
sustainability, elections,
as well as our giving
initiatives.
RADHIKA MALPANI:
Thanks, Anita.
And Julie--
Julie Hanna is a serial
entrepreneur.
You have a wonderful,
illustrious career, including
being an adviser to our startups
and working on
several boards.
Could you tell us a little
bit more about yourself?
JULIE HANNA: Hi.
First of all, it's wonderful
to be here.
I find, at my age, talking about
yourself feels like a
long laundry list of things.
So forgive that.
I'd say, first and foremost,
I'm a technologist.
I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm a former CEO executive.
And what I do today is I use
those experiences to help my
fellow entrepreneurs and
companies kind of go from that
early conception stage into
building companies at scale.
And I do that in a number
of capacities.
Increasingly, the most
meaningful, I'd say,
manifestation of that for
me is in working with
mission-driven entrepreneurs
and companies, particularly
ones that sit at the
intersection of
technology and meaning.
And meaning, for me, kind of
what I define by that, is an
entrepreneur or culture or
company that are driven by a
purpose, by a mission, by a
certain kind of way of wanting
to change the world.
And that really defines my
relationship to technology,
which is really viewing
it as--
I've always been most interested
in the way that
technology impacts our lives
as human beings, how it can
move a human ecosystem forward,
how it can benefit us
both individually and at a group
and on a global level.
And one of the things that I'm
particularly driven around, I
realize, because of having had
the experience of starting and
building a series of five
companies in an operating
capacity, was that doing that in
the Silicon Valley context
allows you to understand how to
go from the earliest stages
to building a company
at scale.
And I think we do that here in
Silicon Valley in a more
highly optimized manner than
anywhere in the world, taking
those skills and harnessing them
and kind of saying, OK,
what are the world's
biggest problems?
The "boil the ocean" problems
that we've tended to
historically think are
intractable, now, with
technology, I believe they're
actually quite
accessible to us.
And so that's really what drives
and motivates me today.
RADHIKA MALPANI: Thank you.
So you're the chairwoman
of Kiva.
Could you tell us a little more
about Kiva, what it does,
what was the basic
idea behind it?
JULIE HANNA: Yeah.
I think the best way to explain
what Kiva is is by
talking about Kiva's
first borrower.
Seven years ago, Kiva's first
borrower was a woman named
Elizabeth Omala.
She was a fishmonger living in
Uganda and had five children.
And she sold fish
by the roadside.
But she wasn't able to make
enough money to send her
children to school.
She was a single mother of
five young children.
And with a $500 Kiva loan, she
was able to make enough money
to buy bus fare to go to Lake
Victoria, which was about four
hours away.
And that allowed her to buy
fish directly from the
fishermen and cut out
the middleman.
And it also allowed her to buy a
small refrigerator where she
could buy larger quantities
of fish.
And with that $500, that one
refrigerator, that one bus
ride, she was able to
scale her business,
increase their profits.
And that allowed her
to begin sending
her children to school.
And from that first borrower
seven years
ago, which was really--
the way that the money was
gathered for that loan, it was
crowd-sourced, but in
a very analog way.
Matt Flannery and Jessica
Jackley, the founders of Kiva,
were on the ground in Uganda.
And they wrote home to friends
and family, because they
believed if anybody had a chance
to meet someone like
Elizabeth and hear her story,
that they would absolutely
want to fund that loan.
And they were overwhelmed
with friends and
family sending in checks.
And from there, Matt, who was
a programmer at TiVo--
and as he often says, I was
spending my days and nights
figuring out how people could
click through movies and TV
much more efficiently--
he sat down, and he developed
this website one night and
thought, how do I scale this up
so we can put more people
like Elizabeth online?
Fast forward seven years, and
today, Kiva has made--
and if you look at it, you can
go to our website, or I think
it's being displayed, maybe,
on the screen--
we have now made about $380
million in loans.
And we'll probably get
to $400 million by
around the year's end.
December is a big part
of our growth.
And that represents about 1
million people having made
loans into 222 countries.
And those loans have gone
to about a million
people in 66 countries.
81% of them are women,
like Elizabeth.
And that represents about half
a million unique loans.
The average loan size
is about $400.
But our biggest loan, which we
had last year, is $50,000.
So they run quite the gamut.
The repayment rate hovers at
about 99%, so very high
repayment rate.
One of the things that I had
someone from the banking
industry recently point out to
me is that it's a repayment
rate that any bank is sort of
lusting after or envious of.
And so that's a little bit about
Kiva in terms of the
speeds and feeds.
But really, I would say the
most important achievement
that Kiva has made, which is not
as talked about, is that
when you look at the loans, it's
easy to sort of look at
the numbers and say, well, this
is money going from this
person to that person.
But really, the money is just
a symbol of something.
There's something far more
important going on in terms of
our humanity.
And one of the greatest impacts
is that when people
have access to capital and are
able to be self-sufficient, it
restores their dignity.
And that's really, I would
say, one of Kiva's most
important achievements, is
seeing the level of dignity
that is restored with people
when you meet the borrowers
and you see how their lives
have been impacted.
One of the first loans I made,
which is sort of my own
emotional favorite, was
a loan to a young
group of women in Cambodia.
And you look at their
picture--
they've formed a sewing
cooperative.
And they're raising $730
for sewing machines.
And so what I realized in
reading their story was that
these young women were survivors
of human sex
trafficking.
And all of a sudden, it makes
you think about a loan
completely differently.
This isn't just $700 and
sewing machines.
The sewing machine is a symbol
for how this person is moving
away from a life of slavery
to a life of freedom and
empowerment and dignity.
And when they repaid their loan,
it wasn't, oh, great,
Kiva has a high repayment
rate.
It was a symbol, evidence, a
marker, of the fact that these
women now were that much
closer to that life of
self-sufficiency and dignity.
So that, to me, is really kind
of underlying it all, one of
Kiva's most profound
achievements.
RADHIKA MALPANI: That's
a lovely story.
JULIE HANNA: So many
stories like that,
so many Kiva stories--
almost a million, to be exact.
RADHIKA MALPANI: Are there some
more stories you'd like
to tell us about the
entrepreneurs?
JULIE HANNA: Well, I think
what I would say is that,
probably in terms of stories,
the thing that is really,
again, maybe not talked about--
but we kind of say
this idea for Kiva is
so counterintuitive.
So if you think about really
what a Kiva pioneer, Muhammad
Yunus was the inspiration
for Kiva.
He proved out that microfinance
could work at scale.
And really, what he was
doing was proving
two important things.
One is that a tiny amount
of money can have a
disproportionate impact on
the lives of the poor.
The other is that the poor were,
in fact, an excellent
credit risk, because the
conventional wisdom in banking
since it's been
institutionalized has been to
exclude the poor and favor
those with money, because
they're considered to be
good for business.
So in a way, you're a good
borrower from a bank when you
don't need the money,
essentially.
And that's been the conventional
wisdom.
And he flipped that
on its head.
Now, what Kiva did was it
brought microlending to the
internet and made it
person-to-person.
So here's where technology's
taking something that was
working on the ground level, but
amplifying it across the
globe, as we know that
technology, and particularly
with the internet, can do.
So seemingly overnight, Kiva
became a global phenomenon
because of the power
of technology.
Making it person-to-person also
had a very subtle but
profound effect, because what
it did is it took people
closer, and it humanized
something.
And it caused us to think about
people living in poverty.
Half the world lives on
less than $2 a day.
And we tend to think of people
living in poverty largely
through the lens of victimhood
and people that need to
handout and need our help.
What Kiva has slowly done is
changing people's perceptions,
that these are entrepreneurs.
They are resourceful
businesspeople.
They are partners.
When I make a loan to you,
it's not a handout.
You repay me.
You're my business partner.
So that shift, that
person-to-person connection,
is quite profound.
The other part of it is the
idea that, gee, someone's
going to want to make a loan to
somebody they've never met
halfway around the world, that
they think that $25 could make
a difference, that that person
would actually want to repay
that back to that random
stranger, just doesn't seem
like an idea that would work,
and certainly not at scale.
And yet, it does.
So you ask yourself,
why is that?
Why does this work?
And why does it keep working?
And I think it fundamentally
has to do with the
person-to-person element, that
we fundamentally want our
lives to matter in small
ways and in big ways.
And part of that is one of the
ways that we instinctively
matter is by being a part
of each other's stories.
We want to be a part of
each other's stories.
And so when I make a loan to
someone, when I made a loan to
that Cambodian sewing
cooperative, in my mind, I
became a part of their story.
And when they repaid their loan,
it told me that in some
small way I played a
small role in their
story getting better.
And I think that's really what
propels Kiva at scale.
RADHIKA MALPANI: Can you tell
us a little bit more about
your lenders?
How often do they get the
money back and reinvest?
You told us some stories about
your entrepreneurs.
Can you tell us any stories from
the lenders' perspective?
JULIE HANNA: Yeah, that's
really a great question.
And it's where some of the
insights around being a part
of each other's stories has
come, from hearing the lenders
talk with great enthusiasm.
I think the things that I kind
of hear from lenders and some
of the lender stories are the
realization that our sense of
the impact that a small amount
of money can have changes.
Sometimes I go to schools and
talk to fifth graders.
Kiva's very big in schools.
And they raise money
to make loans.
And the way they raise money,
oftentimes, is by having a
lemonade stand.
And to hear those lenders
connect the dots, that a woman
in Nigeria who has the vegetable
stand that she's
raising a loan for, that
vegetable stand is not a lot
different from my lemonade
stand, except that $25 or $100
makes a whole lot more
difference for her than it
does for me, because what
does a video game cost?
So even as a young child,
those are the
kind of impacts [? you ?]
[? have ?], the similarities,
the universality
of the human condition.
When you read the borrowers'
stories, I hear a lot of
lenders say, gee, they have
the same hopes and
dreams that we do.
I can't believe how they
can stretch the money
as far as they can.
I can't believe they're able
to repay those loans.
And again, there is a change
from "these are victims" to
"these are really powerful
people that, once they get to
the access to the resources that
they need, can take it a
lot further than any
of us could."
RADHIKA MALPANI: It's funny you
used that example, because
the first time I really looked
into Kiva was when my
daughter's brownie troop had
some money left over.
And they were trying to
figure out what to do.
And they said, instead of
throwing a party, let's just
open Kiva accounts.
So that's what they did.
And my daughter today still
goes back in and
reinvests and reinvests.
JULIE HANNA: That's great.
RADHIKA MALPANI: It's
really funny.
JULIE HANNA: I love hearing
stories like that.
They get a lot better
a lot more quickly
than we do as grownups.
It's really interesting
to see.
RADHIKA MALPANI: Yeah.
That's true.
So let's talk about
Kiva's API.
You guys are very unusual.
Most nonprofits don't
go into that space.
And I'm sure most people aren't
aware of the fact that
Kiva actually has a developer
program and an API.
And I think that might be
very interesting to
our community here.
Could you tell us a little
bit more about it?
JULIE HANNA: Yeah.
First, I'll start by saying that
I think what Kiva does,
the impact it has is so
powerful, the story of it is
so powerful, that oftentimes
what's missed is that, at its
heart, Kiva's a technology
company in a lot of ways.
It's a startup.
It's like a tech startup
with a social mission.
And so when you look at the
culture of Kiva and you look
at the engineering team and
the way that it was built,
there's a lot of
that DNA there.
Then you overlay the fact that
Kiva would not be where it's
at without the community.
The community effect is
incredibly powerful.
For example, I think we have
around 400 translators around
the world that translate
the loans for our site.
And so there is this really
powerful community network
effect, that from the beginning,
I think everyone at
Kiva understands, appreciates,
is so vital to Kiva's success
and to its ability to thrive.
The API is really kind
of born out of that--
what would the community
want to do?
We think of Kiva
as a platform.
It's a marketplace.
It's a person-to-person
marketplace.
Our community probably has a lot
more ideas and imagination
about ways of extending
than we do.
How do we just unleash that and
let 1,000 flowers bloom?
So maybe to bring that to life
through an example, one of the
more powerful examples of that
is the data visualization of
the Kiva loan activity that
was done last year.
And I think we have-- do you
have a video of that that you
want to play?
This might be a good
time to show that.
So what you'll see here is this
is a data visualization
of Kiva's loan activity from
January 2005, when we had the
first loan, into June
of last year.
And each light missile is an
actual loan [INAUDIBLE]
data points [INAUDIBLE].
It's time-lapsed.
You can see over time, as the
activity increases, that's
when PBS Frontline did
a documentary--
Nightline--
and that really told Kiva
about the world.
Oprah discovered Kiva.
Bill Clinton wrote about it
in his book on giving.
And that also drove a lot of
awareness, a lot of activity.
The loans are color-coded
by type of loan.
So you can see the hotspots
starting to form.
And as the loans get repaid,
the light missiles go back.
Crossed the $100 million mark
in November of '09.
ANITA YUEN: It's interesting
which regions seem to pick up
the lighting activity, or the
missile [INAUDIBLE], as well.
JULIE HANNA: Yeah,
the hotspots.
$200 million in March
of last year.
RADHIKA MALPANI: That's an
exponential growth there.
JULIE HANNA: So you can see,
those are where all the
borrowers are located.
These are the lenders.
So that's an example of
the API in action.
And you know, this is
the kind of thing--
this is power in technology.
Before that video was developed,
we all had a sense
of the numbers.
But seeing it brought to life
in this way, you kind of
realize, OK.
In Kiva's first year, we had
3,000 lenders and reached
about a million.
And today, a loan is made
every 7 to 11 seconds.
So far this week, we've
already had I
think it's 1,500 lenders.
Every three days, we grow
by 1,000 lenders.
We hit $1 million in loans
in less than a week.
And there's just so much insight
you can gather from
seeing the information
visualized that way.
So there's a mobile app that
someone did through the API.
So a lot of fun, interesting
examples.
RADHIKA MALPANI: So here at
Google, we obviously deal with
a lot of data.
And so visualization tools
are something we've
really focused on.
So we totally get the
value of that.
So what's are the plans for
Kiva going forward?
What are you hopes,
aspirations?
Where do you see it going?
JULIE HANNA: It's a
very exciting time
right now, very exciting.
We have several exciting
initiatives.
The thing that we lose sleep
over is growth is impact.
So the more people we can reach,
the more lives that are
being impacted.
The growth of Kiva has been
impressive and largely kind of
fueled by technology
and the community
and the network effect.
And at the same time, the
numbers are massive.
Nearly three billion people
in the world don't
have access to capital.
So our mission of--
I always say, Kiva has
democratized access to capital.
That's the lens I look at it
through, because that's the
way I look at technology, is
it's a democratizing force.
So what we think about now is we
expect to reach $1 billion
in loans in the next
two to three years.
That's a very exciting kind
of important mark for us.
Our goal is to have a
self-sustaining model at scale.
So Kiva is a nonprofit, but
I often refer to Kiva as a
not-for-profit or for-revenue
company, because we have a
model of sustainability.
We're still investing in
growth, just like young
companies do, because we have
a big market to address.
So self-sustainability
at scale we see
kind of on the horizon.
In terms of strategically,
there's some very interesting
and exciting things underway.
We have had a pilot for the past
year doing mobile loans.
So our pilots between San
Francisco and Kenya, where you
can make a loan, and the
borrower gets the loan on
their mobile phone, as they
repay their loan, they can do
that on the mobile phone.
And so one of the things we're
always thinking about is, how
do we make that lender-borrower
connection as
strong as possible?
And Matt, the founder/CEO of
Kiva, expresses it really
nicely, because we've gone into
the field and spent time
with the borrowers.
And you have an experience and
say, how do we take this
experience we're having right
now, real-time experience with
this borrower, and export
that to the world?
How do we get every Kiva
lender that experience?
That's what we're always
trying to use
technology to recreate.
The mobile lending brings them
one step closer to that.
And we also think it's how we're
going to reach the next
billion people.
So we talk about $1
billion in loans.
But how do we reach a billion
people around the world?
And the phone is the way that
those populations are coming
online in a big way.
The other thing that's very
exciting on the horizon is we
have begun partnering with
organizations that are just
traditional microfinance
organizations.
So we have about 150
microfinance
partners around the world.
And they're vital to Kiva's
ability to scale, to kind of
be in the field.
And we work very closely
with them.
We've begun to partner with
other types of organizations,
organizations like Soul Sisters,
I believe, in Uganda.
And what they do is they are
basically a distributor of all
kinds of energy products.
And they are really working with
women on the ground to do
that last mile of
distribution.
So now, what you have is a model
that enables women to
increase their incomes and also
serve energy-poor parts
of the world.
And so partners like that are
very exciting to me, because a
lot of these amazing
organizations, amazing
products in the field, having
a hard time really finding
their market, because they
still lack the capital.
Their buyers still
lack the capital.
RADHIKA MALPANI: So you talked
about the receivers.
You've had programs, pilots,
in the past, where you've
tried to get more people to try
out Kiva, to pull them in.
Do you have more plans
like that to reach a
wider range of donors?
JULIE HANNA: Yes.
I'm so glad you asked about
that, because, actually, one
of the things I'm most excited
about, I forgot to talk
about, which is--
so when you think about what
Kiva has done effectively is
kind of at the grassroots level,
people loaning $25 or
more at a time, and then kind
of the scale of that.
The world kind of sees, hey,
there's hundreds of millions
of dollars being lent here at
a very high repayment rate.
The trust and the credibility
and the proof points are there
in terms of repayment.
We increasingly have had
individuals and organizations
say, we'd like to lend larger
amounts of money.
And so our first major loan we
did with a fellow Kiva board
member, Reid Hoffman, who's
the founder of LinkedIn.
And he did a $1 million
loan with Kiva.
And so what we did with that, we
said, rather than just lend
that directly, we will actually
allow people to have
the loan experience using
Reid's money.
And we called it free
loan trials.
So what they did is not only
did it put the $1 million--
[INAUDIBLE]
$1 million reaches 40,000
borrowers--
but we actually brought a
whole bunch of new Kiva
lenders online, giving
that first loan
funded by someone else.
We just did that with
TripAdvisor last week, a
really fun, exciting
announcement--
if you do a review on
TripAdvisor, you can make a
loan, and TripAdvisor's
footing the bill.
So there's sort of a real
leverage effect there, because
we can expose Kiva to more
people, and then we're putting
larger amounts of money into
the system in more
concentrated fashion.
The way I think about Kiva is we
all get kind of trained, in
terms of financial management,
to have these diversified
portfolios.
You put some money in fixed
income and in cash and in
stocks, et cetera.
And so I dream of a world where
people think about Kiva,
or what we sometimes call
connected capital, as an
investment class, an asset
class, where you say, we're
parking tens of thousands of
dollars or hundreds of dollars
in the bank, and the
bank benefits.
No one else really benefits.
We don't benefit.
What if we put that money to
work lending to others?
And we can withdraw that money
any point in time.
Why wouldn't we want
to do that?
ANITA YUEN: And I think many
people would agree
with you, as well.
I think there have been studies
today that talk about
at least 75% of people have the
intention of giving, but
don't for some reason, whether
it's due maybe requiring
research or needing to
understand a little
bit more about it.
But I think what Kiva does
is really simplify the
experience, make it easy for
people to understand what
they're contributing to.
And even things like the mobile,
I think there's a
great opportunity there, as
well, in terms of opportunity.
So that's great that
you guys are
thinking along those lines.
I want to--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANITA YUEN: --to talk a little
bit more about you.
So we'll shift gears a bit.
You have an incredible
background and career.
And you've worked on products
that have reached over tens of
millions of people.
And you've worked on consumer
internet, as well as
enterprise, email communication,
social
networking, gaming.
What drove you to Kiva?
JULIE HANNA: What drove me to
Kiva, I think, was stepping
back a number of years ago at
the height of my professional
success, privately feeling a
personal failure or kind of an
emptiness and a questioning.
And that started me on this
journey of kind of saying, OK,
what really matters most?
Rather than doing this again,
the satisfaction that I
realized that came with just
sort of pure professional
achievement, at best,
was fleeting.
And it left me sort of
wondering, gee, is
this all there is?
And I was pretty exhausted
and burned out.
And so I took that time to
really step back and say,
really, what's driven me?
What's my relationship
to technology been
all of these years?
And in that, I discovered
a few things.
One of those was, when I
connected what I've done
professionally with my own
personal history, you mention
my bio, all the things
that my bio says,
I'm all those things.
I'm a Silicon Valley
entrepreneur who's benefited
disproportionately from being
in this thriving ecosystem.
It's one of the most successful
ecosystems in the world.
And we call it the tech bubble
a lot of the times.
I also have come to think of it
as a bubble of privilege.
And it's easy to forget that,
because bubbles are clear, and
you don't know that you're
in a bubble often, and we
normalize our environments.
But because of my personal
history, in addition to being
all of those things, my journey
to the front lines of
the tech revolution started
on the front lines of war.
I'm an Egyptian immigrant,
and I'm a refugee of war.
And I spent the first many
years of my life kind of
fleeing or living in pretty
adverse circumstances, living
in poverty, and watching
my parents struggle
to make ends meet.
And that instilled in me--
I think it sensitized me to
issues of injustice, seeing
what a lack of access it does
to a person, how it defines
people, how people treat you
when you don't have access.
I remember, in my mind, we were
just a family sort of
getting those through things.
We were no different
from anyone else.
But we had our own kind
of challenges.
But what I would notice is the
way other people looked at us
after we immigrated to
the United States.
And one of my most vivid
memories is that they would
look at us often through
the eyes of pity.
And they would, in a very
well-meaning way, offer us a
handout, because they thought
charity was the
best way to help us.
And charity did help us
at crucial times.
But what it also did was it
chipped away at our dignity.
And after a while, what happens
with that is you start
to internalize that lens of how
people are looking at you.
And then that can be incredibly
disempowering.
So all of those things really
instilled in me a sense of
being very driven around issues
of fair access, wanting
to bring justice to the world.
I was lucky enough to have
gotten a sense from my father
that there was nothing
I couldn't do.
So I felt a drive about that,
despite my circumstances.
And that's all kind of a long
way of saying that I kind of
walked around feeling this thing
that we sometimes hear
about, which is that talent is
universal, but opportunity
isn't, and that it's not a level
playing field, even in
the land of equal opportunity.
And so when I came out of
college, when I looked at
technology, I really viewed
technology as a democratizing
force, as a great leveler.
And it did give fair access
to people who
didn't have it before.
And that's really been what
drove me in my career, first
around digital communications
and email.
When I looked at email in the
'80s in the lab, I kind of
said, you know, I think one
day we're all going to
communicate this way.
This is going to be
like the phone.
But in searching for that deeper
meaning and bringing
alignment to my work, in terms
of what I held most dearly,
that really led me towards the
work that Kiva was doing and
looking at empowerment and
democratizing forces.
I think technology is the most
democratizing force the
planet's known.
I also came to believe that
entrepreneurs are the biggest
change agents in the world.
And so how could I help
technology entrepreneurs have
a greater impact in the world?
And that's really sort of what
led me towards Kiva and some
of the philosophical threads
underpinning that.
Probably a longer answer than
you wanted to know.
ANITA YUEN: No, that's great.
You've touched on
a few points.
When I heard as soon as you
mentioned how your father
said, there's nothing you can't
be doing, and then you
mentioned the level playing
field, immediately I thought
of the baseball story.
And you can share with our folks
here a little bit more
about the baseball story.
JULIE HANNA: Yeah.
Megan must have had something
to do with this.
I don't know how that
secret got out.
Yeah, so my family
moved to the US.
As a young girl, I was
discovering everything American.
And nothing more American
than baseball.
And I loved baseball,
was deeply
passionate about baseball.
And my family moved to a small
Southern town, really small,
and so small that we were known
as the foreign family,
because we were basically
the only
non-American family in town.
And I discovered baseball.
And I said, this is great,
I want to play.
And I was quickly told that I
couldn't play baseball because
it's a boys-only support--
Little League baseball,
I guess, was and
probably still is.
And that just seemed deeply
unjust to me.
And I was kind of determined to
appeal my case to someone.
And largely, a bunch of
adults were apathetic.
Nobody really cared.
They're like, yeah, get over
it, you can go play in the
backyard, kind of thing.
And so I was really
determined.
The idea that someone could or
couldn't do something based on
who they were really hit me
and probably because of
everything that I'd experienced
to that point.
Doing it because the fact that
someone could or couldn't do
something because of whether
they were a boy or a girl
really got my back up.
And I was determined to
prove girls could do
anything boys could do.
And somewhere along the way, I
learned about Title IX, which
had just been passed.
And for those of you who don't
know, Title IX was the Equal
Opportunity Act that basically
said that if a sport was being
offered to one gender, it had to
be made available to both.
It was very new.
Not many people knew about it.
And if it were today, I would
have gone on the internets and
found the Google and looked
it up and said,
how do I play baseball?
And all this great information--
well, then, that
wasn't the case.
So it took a little
detective work.
So on the day of baseball
registration, I'd decided I
had the law on my side.
And I marched to City Hall,
which is where you register
for baseball.
And to this day, I remember
walking up and really being
terrified--
because it was all a bunch
of grownups, and I
was 12 at the time--
and walking up to the window.
And they said, well, what
are you doing here?
And well, I'm here to register
for baseball.
And this elderly Southern woman
looks down at me, and I
can see that look of pity.
She's like, oh, bless
your heart, hon.
Girls don't play baseball.
Now run along.
And so I gave her a filibuster
on Title IX.
And I don't know if they
eventually relented because I
wouldn't shut up or if
they saw the light.
But they let me play baseball.
And it was a pretty horrific
thing for a small town to have
a girl play baseball.
It really kind of upset
everybody's ideas about the
way things were supposed
to be.
But what I think was really
interesting in hindsight was I
like to think that I changed
those attitudes just a little
bit about the fact that girls
can do anything boys can do.
And in hindsight, I actually
realized that it taught me
almost all the vital things that
I needed to know about
entrepreneurship.
And I think of entrepreneurs
as activists, really.
It was activism.
But activists and entrepreneurs
have a lot in common.
And so I draw a lot on that
experience to this day.
ANITA YUEN: Great.
Well, maybe you can talk about
that a little bit more.
So you've been a CEO.
Clearly, you're a board
chairperson, a founder,
entrepreneur.
What are other ingredients
that you apply
to secrets of success?
JULIE HANNA: I always feel
like an impostor when I'm
asked that question, because I
can't say that I've really had
a methodical way of looking
at my career.
And I don't walk around and say,
well, here's my secret
sauce, let me pull some
out of pocket and
add it to this meal.
But if anything, I
would attribute--
I think, one, there's
the definitions of
success that I challenge.
They're social, societal
definitions of success.
And the question is, can we
define our own personal
definition of success that
isn't entirely defined by
external things?
The other is that not worrying
about success would be my
secret sauce if I had one.
I never thought about whether
I'd be successful or not.
And I don't mean that
make in a glib way.
I kind of imagine someone
watching who's going, oh,
yeah, easy for you to say at
this point, because, gee,
you've been fortunate.
And I have been fortunate.
But I think part of not worrying
about success is not
having goal orientation
and all that.
It's not that you're not clear
about why you do what you do.
It's not that you're
not driven.
It's just that you don't have a
predisposed idea about what
the outcome is going
to be like.
And I meet young people and
entrepreneurs all the time who
are so with it, so together.
And they come up to me, and they
say, here's what I did.
And they're well educated.
And I look at them and think,
god, you're way more together
than I am now, much less
when I was your age.
But sometimes, I think what's
happened is we have fallen
prey to thinking we can
codify everything.
So talking about technology,
right?
It's like, what's the
program for success?
And I think there are
definitely markers for success.
But I think we can become
slaves to those.
So a gift for me is I had no
idea about any of that.
And what that did is I thrive
on learning and not thinking
about the outcome.
I was driven by what
my values were.
What am I trying to do?
I want to do something
important.
I want to have impact.
I want to do something
significant.
I want to learn.
And that created sort
of just an openness
and a sense of adventure.
Whenever I took a new job, I
never thought about whether I
can be successful or not.
What I thought about is, can I
do what they need, and can I
have an impact, and this
is going to matter?
Actually, one of the things that
came out in a reference
check years ago that someone
did on me was--
which I was deeply hurt by at
the time, and I realized is
absolutely true about me--
when I'm motivated
around something,
there's no stopping me.
And if I'm not motivated, I'm
like a different person.
And so, really, what has always
propelled me is that
passion and that desire to
learn, and then being driven
by the value, the meaning, the
what's this for, the why--
why am I doing this?
Not what do I do.
Why am I doing it?
Do I deeply believe in this?
And that's how I think
about startups.
Startups are all about, we're
going to go change the world
in this way.
So that just has always
really propelled me.
ANITA YUEN: Wow, that's
wonderful.
And I imagine you'd be a role
model for many of us watching
it or around us here.
Maybe you can tell us a bit more
about your role model?
You mentioned your father
earlier in terms of what you
sort of go back to, in terms
of not accepting the status
quo, and there's nothing
you can't do.
Are there other role models
that you look
up to in your life?
JULIE HANNA: This is
the other question
I really hate getting.
ANITA YUEN: Well, I'm glad I
can ask you these questions
that you don't like.
JULIE HANNA: There
are so many.
I didn't grow up saying, this
is one person I'm going to
really model after them.
I think our role models, in many
ways, are people that we
don't know who they were until
much later and look back and
say, that person has
such a formative--
because it's more implicit
than explicit.
And I certainly have those
people in my life.
I think one of the things
I realized I do is--
and this probably comes out
of the curiosity and the
learning; back to, gee,
secret sauce--
I think I'm kind of just
naturally a learning machine.
And I always find something
to learn from
everybody that I meet.
Now I try to make
it conscious.
But it was just always
sort of who I was.
And so there's nothing that--
everyone has something
to teach us.
I really believe that.
And I could look back on people
that I didn't like
working with, people
I struggled with.
Everybody has something
to teach you.
And so in many ways, everybody
I've ever come in contact with
is a role model in one
way or another.
But I would say the other thing
is I always look at who
am I surrounding with myself
that's a source of
inspiration for me.
And I think we need that to be
our best as human beings,
which is why it's such an
important question, even
though I'm giving you a
hard time about it.
And I would say, maybe, since
we're talking about Kiva,
there are three people
that come to mind.
One of them, a longtime hero,
who I'm pleased to say is now
a friend, is Muhammad Yunus.
And the reason he's a role model
for me is because he
connects very tangible
on-the-ground humanity to the
broadest principles.
And he is an agent of
change in that way.
But he's not lost his humanity
and his capacity to
connect in that way.
And that's really what fuels
his power, and he has been
doing and is able to do, is
he takes that, and he can
abstract that into very broad
and important powerful
principles to change
the world.
And I deeply admire that.
It's something I aspire to.
I would say that another source
of daily inspiration
for me is Matt Flannery, the
founder and CEO of Kiva.
Matt brings such an integrity
and a commitment in his work.
And I would say that we never
always live from our "why,"
but he, maybe as much
as anyone I know, is
connected to that.
It's easy to do that
when we do the work
that we do at Kiva.
But I see a lot of people doing
mission-driven work,
where you get disconnected from
the "why." And he has
that compass of integrity.
And he is very human.
Again, he brings his humanity to
his work and to the way he
is in the world.
And I deeply admire that.
And then, the last person that
comes to mind, somebody I
mentioned earlier, who's a
fellow board member and also a
dear friend and colleague,
is Reid Hoffman.
Reid has found a way to manifest
what he values on a
large scale.
And he retains that kind of
integrity and humanity.
So I guess integrity, humanity,
and values, maybe,
are the things that are really
inspiring to me.
ANITA YUEN: Well, those are
amazing people to be
surrounded by.
RADHIKA MALPANI: So before we
run out of time, we have a few
questions from the audience.
Do you want to read it?
ANITA YUEN: Sure.
So the top one is,
"Self-sustaining model at scale--
can you talk about how you are
intending to make the mobile
loans self-sustaining
and at scale?
JULIE HANNA: Oh, just
start out with
a really hard question.
So the mobile loans-- so Kiva's
this model is that, in
terms of how we support
ourselves, when you make a
loan, 100% of the lender's money
goes to the borrower
that they've chosen
to lend money to.
And then, when you check out,
when you sort of say, OK, I
want to make this loan, we give
you the option to make a
donation to Kiva.
We call it a tip, basically, to
tip us like you would in a
restaurant.
And that's our revenue model.
That's our earned
income model.
So it's the same with mobile
loans as it is with if you
make a loan on a
website today.
How we're going to make mobile
work at scale is something
we're still figuring out.
It's one of the biggest
strategic questions on the
table right now.
So I can't really elaborate
on that right now.
But if you have any great
ideas for us, we'd
love to hear them.
RADHIKA MALPANI: So before we
close, do you have any advice
for young entrepreneurs,
especially young women trying
to get into technology?
JULIE HANNA: Yeah.
I would say the thing that
helped me the most--
and it's so much easier to do
this today-- is I would
connect the dots, connect the
dots on what is it about
technology you love, connect
the dots between technology
and something you're really
passionate about, because I
think that when you do that,
that will tap the creativity,
the innovation, the passion
for your work.
So today, technology is so much
about, what can we enable?
What parts of our lives, of
the world, is it going to
change, enable?
What are the things that
you care about?
And then think about, what role
can technology play here,
rather than just looking at
things through a pure
technology lens.
That really helped me.
My only way of being able to do
that when I was in college
was by the co-op program, where
you could go figure out
an applied way of using
computer science.
And I became a programmer and
learned a lot about what my
day-to-day life was
going to be like.
And I quickly realized that
really what I care most about
is how it's going to
affect our lives.
And that guided the first job
I took out of college, and
that got me going
on a trajectory.
So it's really sort of
connecting the dots.
RADHIKA MALPANI: OK.
ANITA YUEN: Great.
RADHIKA MALPANI: I think
we're out of time.
ANITA YUEN: Yeah, I think
So thank you so much for
joining us today.
It's been great learning about
Kiva, as well as hearing about
all the inspiration that you
bring to everyone around
through Kiva, as well as all the
CEOs, entrepreneurs that
you helped coach today.
We want to thank you for joining
us for the second
series of Women Techmakers.
We're here again tomorrow, 2:30
PM, PST, with Jen Pahlka
for Code for America.
And stay tuned to learn
more about tech
women for social impact.
Thanks.